you know I had a vibration here
I won these leaks in sound right
[Music]
the goddesses invaded as God
I'm going to stop loan don't put
together team
he's a fighter
surprise
by
dis film - tastings and language that
may be inappropriate for younger viewers
so much has happened since I last saw
you
I lost my hammer like yesterday so
that's still pretty fresh
and then I went on a journey of
self-discovery
let you
[Music]
why are we you have no idea how long the
goddess of death is invaded as God oh
I've missed this
and you and I had a fight person I did I
word now I want easily doesn't sound
right
uh that's true
as god is dead we'll be reborn in Miami
I thought you'd be glad to see me need a
stopper here now to prevent Ragnarok the
end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
at the old days
surprise this would be such fun
hi
he's a fighter
here we go
I'm not a queen
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
[Music]
we're the same you and I just a couple
of hotheaded fools yes same all quite
fire door like water I kind of both like
fire but a whole like raging fire so I
like smoldering fire
you